foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
this is the Ramsey show where America
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money I'm Ramsey
personality George Campbell joined today
by the infamous Dr John deloney some
call it the Dream Team some call it
America's Nightmare and you get to
choose today as the universe a dream
team no that was just me that was
aspirational I appreciate your
aspirations well we are here for you
America give us a call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five uh John
deloney he can answer almost every
question but he's really great at the
ones concerning mental health
relationships boundaries marriage you
name it and I'll jump in on the money
questions and nerd out with you so if
you're trying to get out of debt you've
got some anxiety you're going through a
hard time a hard time like I am right
now John very emotional to sort of show
but we're a dream team so I'll pick up
when you go through hard times that's
what we're gonna it's a great teammate
well John on is kicking us off in
Knoxville Tennessee John welcome to the
show
hey thanks for everything you guys do
sure how can we help today
so I'm looking for some advice opinions
on hopefully purchasing our first home
in six to eight months cool
and I can give some context on that
please do
all right so I'm on baby step 3B so we
have zero debt we just had our second
daughter one week ago congratulations
that was a big thing I appreciate it and
we have officially outgrew our 800
square foot home it's actually my dad's
name we've been living here for a while
and we're needing a bigger home for sure
now are you paying him around what
um for all the land taxes for the 13
acres so that's that's the majority of
what we do awesome
um one important piece of information is
uh my wife and I we are have our
daughters in uh or our oldest daughter
currently in private school and we're
not a fan of public and homeschool so
that has a big play to do with this new
home that we're wanting to get into
in what way
financially so we yeah we live pretty
far away from any kind of private school
about 50 minutes we're driving one way
now so our first option that we have is
my dad actually gifted us five acres of
land it's in our name
um so we would have to build though and
that would require 60 to 80 000 in land
prep so of course that takes away from
the amount of home that we can build
and of course we're very far away from
the schools almost an hour one way so
that
that's one option that's on the five
acres you're an hour away
yeah correct and that's currently where
we're at now it's just the next Mountain
over where we would build
um
and our second option we're thinking
about is uh moving to the city renting
for a little bit and then buying a house
if we like the area probably and
actually in the Knoxville area
we would be close to the school but then
we'd be very awake very far away from
both my parents and my wife's parents
um and our oldest daughter is completely
against moving so that's that part to do
with it how old is she
uh only eight years old okay so there's
a there's a reason why we
as a society have all pitched in and and
and we've all said hey you know what
let's don't let eight-year-olds buy beer
or uh guns or drive cause they're eight
right so just for whatever it's worth
she gets zero votes none no votes at all
you could move her to the moon and if
you're a good parents uh she's gonna
she's gonna be fine so she doesn't get a
vote yeah I'll jump back in there let me
let me back out a little bit let me tell
you this I've learned this the hard way
with two kids
um I moved out to the woods and it was
good for our family and from moving
downtown Nashville to into the woods
with two kids it's been awesome and my
wife spends an incredible amount of time
in the car
and it definitely takes away from
um
so many other things that we had dreamed
of doing is simply getting to and from
different places and so I would much
rather see you build a life worth living
and then go to your parents on the
weekends versus here's what you're
trying to do you're trying to keep your
life exactly the same and you just added
another kid and you'll have this value
which is
where he'd rather drive two hours a day
than send our kids to public school and
be invested in the public school system
and help it grow and morph and change
um we want to spend two hours in the day
in the car like you see what I'm saying
you're creating all these variables for
yourself and then you're frustrated that
your life isn't smooth
um
does that make sense
yeah yes it does based on everything you
just told me I'm going with your second
option which is we're going to move into
the city we're going to buy a house
there when we're ready to do it maybe
that means we rent for a year or two
while we save up how much money do you
have saved right now
first three we currently have fifteen
thousand dollars for our emergency fund
we have about ten thousand dollars
towards the house but in six to eight
months we should have about thirty
thousand to put down so what I'm hearing
is every six months you can save up
another twenty thousand
yeah yeah we have uh three thousand
minimum months going towards uh a down
payment okay so what is that means forty
a year which means in two years you
could have eighty on top of your ten
which puts it at 90. and now we're
looking at a healthier down payment
because I'm guessing to live in the city
is going to be more expensive
yeah but we're currently not paying rent
right now so that will have play in
effect with how quickly we've spent if
we move to the city for sure great the
other thing would be just gritting your
teeth for another 18 24 months and at
the 800 square foot house
yeah yeah
you just said definitely an option it's
rough but it's an option yes um your
eight-year-old say oh yeah you don't get
you get so few votes you get to sleep in
a tent in the backyard for the next two
years don't do that
um hey let me ask you why
what do you pay in private school
tuition
uh it's 400 a month okay
and that's worth it to your family
oh yeah for sure okay
okay well think you have your answer if
you want to stick it out there for a
while do that until you can't stand it
any longer and then we're moving to the
city and probably renting for another
year because we need a lot more money
saved up because I want you to do this
the right way the smart way and not with
impulse that means a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage with 10 to 20 percent down if
you're able to and have that payment be
no more than a quarter of your take-home
pay so that gives you your timeline
parameters pretty easily you don't
really have to wonder at that point
okay so start looking around and see
what you can get in that area and and
I'm sure there's some great spots you
can rent and it's going to be a lot more
than you're paying now because right now
you're paying pennies so that's going to
be part of your budget
all right thank you so much yeah man
thanks so much for the call good luck
with uh with the move and the changes
George I see this a lot we're
people just want to have all of it and
you want the cake and you want to eat it
and they don't want to be uncomfortable
right and
um and I made this mistake I've talked
about this from stage talking whenever
my wife said she was pregnant I thought
to myself okay cool
nine to ten months-ish and then I'll get
my wife back right and I don't even know
what that meant I just thought then
we'll be able to go back to our life
will go to normal Crazy Life we had when
we were single we'll just have another
human and they'll be fine and then after
a few months after my son was born I was
like it's probably gonna be a little bit
longer probably another 12 months and
then then I'll we can go back to the way
things were and there is no going back
right and so now they've reached to
they've crossed a new line which is oh
we have a second kid and that would mean
if we're gonna choose to continue to do
private school that's two tuitions and
50 minutes in the car here and all of a
sudden this life we had imagined is very
different and so yeah complex
reconstruct your house every time you
have a major change in it amen and I
lived in a 900 square foot house growing
up I feel like this dates me here John
but we survived everybody's everybody
everybody lives you sit on one couch
it's fine you don't need that much space
well you're not a huge guy that's true
thanks for reminding America it's your
show America triple eight eight two five
five two two five
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
talking money around here but we know
not everybody feels that way and that's
why Rachel Cruz and myself started
thinking about what it would be like to
talk money for those of you who'd rather
just have fun so last week we launched a
brand new Ramsay network podcast called
smart money happy hour Rachel and I we
dig into the stuff you and your friends
would talk about at your weekly happy
hour things like pop culture what's
going on in the world and how you can
afford the life you love it's fun casual
entertaining money advice that will make
you feel less stressed and More in
control of your money plus we have a
really good time some call it hilarious
that's a review from John deloney on
Apple podcast thank you for that one
John you and Rachel Cruz are the
original Dream Team wow I I was called
Regis Philbin and I took that as a
compliment I would I would take that
also all the way to the concert Kathy
Lee so and we promise while it's
entertaining you actually Walk Away
Learning something there's some good
takeaways in there so if this sounds
like something you're interested then go
ahead and subscribe to Smart money happy
hour wherever you listen to podcasts
that way you'll get notified every
single Thursday when we release a new
episode we've got two out already it
charted at number one number one man
congratulations thank you on the
business charts it's number one on
Spotify in the business charts as well
as apple and we charted at number 19
overall out of all the podcasts in the
world which is amazing so thank you all
for sharing subscribing leaving your
feedback leaving reviews five stars all
of it we super appreciate it the team
has done an incredible job with this one
all right open phones this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Brian is up next in Bowling Green Brian
welcome to the show
hey what's going on man not much how are
you what can we help with today
well uh I'm I'm kind of in uh kind of in
a crossroads right now right now I'm
about 48
837 uh dollars and um student loan debt
I'm in the middle of trying to become a
doctor uh MD
um and I'm trying to you know get a good
MCAT score and get in uh as I'm in
between jobs I'm just trying to find
something that I can uh uh
uh do
um and I have a couple of offers a car
salesman position a retail position over
at Sam's or maybe try and find something
in a hospital I'm not sure who's going
to be getting to me first but what do
you guys suggest
well on first blush the hospital one
seems like it would give you some
valuable experience since that's where
you're wanting to go
right yes it's just that they're taking
forever to get back to me and I'm not
even and I'm looking at the pay and
hopefully I'm not sure how long this
interim of uh stall of payments is going
to last out I'm not sure if they're
going to extend it again depending on
what happens in November and whatnot
they're not going to and yeah
um
here's what's concerning and so I've I
spent a
um the last few years before I came to
Ramsey Solutions researching the mental
health of attorneys and lawyers uh I'm
attorneys and doctors and a couple other
groups
the doctors who are successful you can't
keep them out of the medical service
profession
and I'm already concerned about why you
would want to go to med school and also
be considering a job selling used cars
is this just a simply a I I need it's a
dollars and cents thing I can just make
way more money doing this right now
um because if you're already like well
you know I don't know if it's worth it
right now or they're taking forever dude
medical school is going to eat your
lunch
why do you want to be a doctor
to be able to help people and do work
that uh truly matters to be able to take
someone who's suffering and be able to
help them out in a uh reasonable and
impact their life like greatly so how
can anybody in the world keep you out of
a hospital right now
sweeping floors doing whatever it takes
yeah I mean just I
just not much sir like it's I'm I'm I've
been fighting for this for you know
coming on a decade now and I'm I'm still
plugging I'm still fighting I'm just
trying to find some way to keep the
lights on right now there you go okay
that's that's what I need to know that's
cool and the other side of uh any sort
of long-term dream like this right is
I'll do anything it takes in the interim
to make this thing happen so I honor
that too man that's good good for you
um
I just want to make sure you know what
you're biting off but it sounds like you
this has been your dream for a long long
time trust me I did quantitative
analysis in organic chemistry trust me I
I know what I'm getting
you've paid your debt hey if you get
through okay man you get through much so
um I'll turn over to George with the
with the with the dollars and sins part
of this
um
go ahead and buckle up for Education
institutions medical institutions they
move glacially
just gotta settle in man it's just the
DMV it takes it's like the DMV if the
DMV wanted to slow things down a bit
ouch all right are there other hospitals
in your area that you've checked out
yes I've gone through the major ones
that are in the area
um and I am about to today I'm going to
start applying to the smaller clinics
like it's just literally anything I
would I would focus my energy on small
clinics
um I keep hearing anecdotally about the
shortages on everything from cleaners to
people running gurneys to people running
um you know the more Gary I mean people
just shortages everywhere and so yeah I
would get my applications out all over
the place and in the meantime if you
want to go work at a Wholesale Club to
make 20 bucks an hour so you can start
stacking up absolutely heck yeah that's
great
and then you can move on if you get a
full-time role at a hospital doing what
you want to do that's great too
yeah I mean you know dreams are nice but
you know the rent's doing the first you
know yes yeah you can't pay your light
bill with with
you know dragon's tears you gotta
actually go make real money and I love
that you're willing to do whatever it
takes right now and willing to be
Scrappy about it yeah it tells me you're
you're off to a good start don't take
the delay as something personal it's
just it's it's the nature of that Beast
right now and so go just keep grinding
the grinding someone's going to be lucky
to have you thanks for the call Brian
appreciate it Kelsey's up next in Baton
Rouge Kelsey welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you
um I wanted to get your advice my
husband and I are trying to make a
difficult decision
um we're on our debt-free journey and
we've got two daughters that are young
but exceptionally talented at gymnastics
and we're trying to decide if we should
sell our home to become debt free and to
be able to continue to support their
gymnastics or should we stay in our home
and maybe pull them out so that we can
really kick start our our baby step
Journey
wow why is selling the house your first
option
we have a lot of equity in our home
um and I guess sometimes we just feel
like we'd be pretty happy in a more
modest home
that's a reason to sell it not
so that we can
be able to ship our kids all over the
country
yeah if I I I'm really hesitant for you
to use your kids as an excuse to make
any sort of decision you all need to
make what's the best decision for your
family and your living needs and your
financial situation and then the kids
come on the back end of that
sure they can't carry the weight of
their parents hopes and dreams we sold
the house for you to do gymnastics and
now you don't want to do gymnastics
anymore now you just want to smoke
cigarettes yeah and they can't carry
that weight you know what I mean they
can't they wouldn't want to do that I
will say we originally had planned on
selling our home so we could quickly
we're ready to get there but then we
recently had the thought that we could
just take them out of gymnastics and
make it work to stay in this house which
is where I guess how much is gymnastics
costing you
um gymnastics for both of them total is
870 a month wow good and that doesn't
include travel does it
um it doesn't but the majority of our
meets are local and I'm pretty sure we
have the option to decline any travel at
this stage since they're so young so
what would something in your gut says
put taking them out on the table what is
it
either way we end up hopefully with a
paid for house at 40 years old
completely debt free but one option is
they're still in gymnastics but we're in
a more modest Zone whereas the other
option is staying in this home taking
them out and and then we have a much
nicer home that's paid for
hmm I would look at cutting all other
expenses increasing income taking on
side jobs and staying in the home and
selling the home to me is a last-ditch
option unless you guys just hate this
house and want to move anyways but
that's a huge step to take just to keep
affording gymnastics yeah again I would
not do this because of gymnastics if
gymnastics if you're able to afford it
because you've done this fine I always
want parents to ask themselves are we
keeping our kids in after school sports
and Elite travel stuff to fulfill our
dreams or for our kids most kids just
want time with their parents
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
host of the fine print and co-host of
the smart money Happy Hour podcast
hosting today with my friend Dr John
deloney host of the Dr John deloney show
you can check out all of those shows on
the Ramsey Network and wherever you
listen to podcasts open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's talk about your life your
money boundaries relationships mental
health issues we are here to serve you
America Mike joins us up next in
Columbus Ohio Mike welcome to the show
hey good afternoon good afternoon to you
I've been I've been saving uh to
purchase a home and uh I've been looking
for the last year or so
hasn't been much of opportunity on the
market I'm currently renting and I built
up a fairly large liquid cash position
as I've been saving up
and I'm worried about the impact of
inflation on that uh particular savings
sure how much do you have
uh currently in liquid 105 000 awesome
and where is that currently saved
it's uh currently in a Bank savings
account making probably point zero zero
one percent
yeah you can do
Mike you said disappointed in Mike now
have you heard about like a high yield
savings account
online
uh
yes or no
for the most part I've been just parking
money and haven't really been thinking
about it much okay we love a savings
account for that kind of short-term
savings I don't want you investing this
money but there are better options for
savings accounts and one is that online
high yield savings account I've got one
right now it's you're I'm getting 2.6
percent which is incredible compared to
what it's been the last few years so
interest rates have been climbing on
those savings accounts which is great so
you can do a lot better on that money
[Music]
compounded or is that annual
um that would be annual it would get
compounded because you get 2.6 every
year
and so as you earn that 2.6 you're going
to earn 2.6 on that amount now and so uh
it's a it's a great deal for to keep
your cash liquid yes you could invest it
in the market but as we've seen uh you
know my 401k is down like 25 so I'd be
real upset if I was in the spot even
looking at mine John just doesn't look
probably not Lucas
so Mike that's what I would do if I was
in your shoes you're on to a great start
I mean is that enough money to get you a
down payment right now for the house
you're looking at
yep it is
um and uh about 20 for the range that
I'm looking at which is pretty good
what's your what's your hand there's
something sitting like not sitting in
your soul right what is it
um
immediacy of action because I'm looking
to purchase a house right now I'm going
I've been renting for a little bit I'm
going to month to month okay because I
had a house that was lined up uh with a
good offer and it kind of fell through
okay
I believe so yeah okay I have a tendency
Mike to get frustrated with the
situation and go do something to shake
the snow globe and I make a mess
so the hardest part for you is to not
let this 100 Grand burn a hole in your
pocket and your frustration with renting
make you do make a a foolish long-term
decision
whether that's to go dump all this money
into an index fund and lose 10 percent
of it over the next year because the
Market's still fluctuating and you need
the cash or to go buy a house that you
really don't like but you're just sick
of all
man you need to just be patient even if
you have a friend you say hey your job
is to make ask me these questions before
I go do something stupid right you're
not going to earn 20 you're not going to
earn back inflation you're not going to
earn back 8.3 or 8.6 whatever it is
you're not going to earn that back in a
liquid account you're just not so you
got to make peace with inflation is what
it is but I am interested in holding on
to this cash right now does that make
sense
yeah it does so can I ask you one other
question really quick sure how would you
differentiate this from an emergency
savings account and how would you handle
the two differently
I mean I would keep them in different
accounts so that I don't go into the
cookie jar and then go oh that was my
emergency fund but I keep the majority
of my emergency fund in a high high
yield online savings account
and so that's where I would tell you to
put that Home Savings as well
now they're different in separate
accounts you can create multiple
accounts with those
um with those Banks but I'm looking at
the numbers now you could be making 2
700 bucks a year right now if it was in
a high yield savings instead of close to
zero that comes out to a little over 200
bucks a month but let me tell you Mike
the secret sauce is not the interest
rate it's Mike
you putting money away living on lesson
you make that is the secret sauce to
beating inflation
not a savings rate
and you've done that you've done it man
I mean how many people look up and go I
got 100 Grand in the bank and I'm ready
to buy a house and I'm ready to do it
the smart way
so now you've done the work you said 100
Grand was enough to get this house right
so now it's the game of patience like
John's talking about we're going well I
want to buy the right house
and not just because I'm sick of renting
this is the biggest purchase you've ever
made in your life right
and yep so I'm gonna walk with a lot of
caution a lot of wisdom work with a
great real estate agent and Desperation
leads to bad financial decisions and
when you can do it with patients and
you're not in a rush that's when you can
actually get the best deal because
you're not feeling impulsive so just get
it now and not negotiate and take your
time and walk away if it's not a great
deal
all right so you've done great man the
one move I'd make is just switching it
over to high-yield uh savings account
and at least for now you'll feel better
making that 200 bucks a month so thanks
for the question it's a good one and
George you and I've talked about this
offline just when we're hanging out the
Green Room Somewhere talking about how
we each do how much we actually live
these principles out in our own lives
and I have my emergency fund in the same
place with my checking account I I earn
I may earn a high five every year right
annually
um it's for me it's not worth
I need to pull up this bank and I don't
have you know I don't keep apps on my
phone so it's it's just a personal
decision I think the main thing is do
you know where it is and can you get to
it in the case of an emergency liquid
yeah yeah and we always say an emergency
fund is Insurance not an investment and
a lot of people look at 10 20 30 grand
and they're going well John that's
unsophisticated you should put that you
could invest that money that's the wise
thing to do it's not an investment it's
meant to protect you yes it's sleep
Insurance there you go I can go on a on
a vacation and something goes wrong
that's fine you got the money yeah
that's right that's a good word all
right Dave joins us up next in Erie
Pennsylvania Dave welcome to the show
well thank you for taking my call today
sure how can we help
well I'm I'm real quickly I'm 58 and a
half every day millionaire uh um debt
free I'm going to continue to work when
I'm 59 and a half and can utilize my
401k is it okay to use it at that time
to purchase
um a new vehicle
and let that ride for a while and build
back up and then purchase my wife a new
vehicle and use that as a as a vehicle
fund will you still be working at that
point
that's correct yeah I'm still going to
continue to work I'm still going to
continue to contribute to it and I
thought that might be just as simple as
as you know saving up and and uh using
that fund for that and you're completely
debt free
yes sir home and everything
yep everything I I owe nothing uh worth
about uh 1.25 way to go and uh you know
we we cash flow everything and and uh
just that's it that's a lot of money to
build up you know when a new vehicle
costs I thought geez you know if I can
hang on with some old uh old 2006
vehicles for another year I can utilize
that fund but uh you know take in the
current uh Financial State of the
country and everything I just wonder if
that was if that was okay to do so I
want to ask a question to George Dave on
your question sparked the question with
me and so both of you answer this
why wouldn't Dave and or George I guess
just stop making payments to the 401 and
go ahead and just save up cash
it's going to take you a few months but
why would you why would you end up owing
yourself
I could do that and I just wonder what
is it six one half does the other what's
what what's what would be the difference
I I don't know I guess my question is
why wouldn't you just save up in cash
flow it with your income I mean you've
done so great you've stayed out of debt
you're doing all the stuff the right way
I just wouldn't want to rob my
retirement you know to start my
retirement off as soon as you can pull
the money out and Rob the growth that's
happening in that account how much is in
that account
um uh One Fund has has right around uh
one million and another one has about
about 200 250 000. I mean doing the math
on what the compound growth of that
account is today and taking 40 grand out
of that to buy a car it would just hurt
me emotionally yeah and so I would go
I'm gonna cash flow it and I'm probably
gonna make a different decision if I'm
cash flowing it versus taking out of my
retirement and so I would just tread
with caution there there's nothing wrong
with it I just don't think you need to
and so I would just save up with your
future income with savings and do it
that way versus robbing the retirement
on day one that's one man's take but
congrats man you've done a great job
super happy for you this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
of the day comes from blinds.com find
out for yourself why they're the number
one online retailer of custom window
covering you get free samples free
shipping with the new promos they run
every month you'll save even more use
promo code Ramsay to get the best deal
all right today's question comes from
Marge in Florida
that's right I said that right Marge in
Florida that's right all right I've been
going through various Church videos on
the YouTubes to try to connect to a good
church in hopes of having a pastor
inspire me to continue listening to his
sermons oh boy
I thought I found one I was considering
giving a donation but when I went to the
giving page on the website there was a
box I've not seen on other churches
sites
the option to give with stock or crypto
it surprised me because it's a new way
to raise finances but I'm not sure if
there are tax implications have you
heard of this happening and what's your
take on this
wow this is honestly a first for me John
I'm Googling it and there are many
articles talking about how this is
becoming a trend with churches offering
this as an option why would the church
accept a a failing pseudo currency well
that's the big question John
that's where my heart's at you can give
us cash check or just a bucket of gravel
we'll take that too
yeah I mean my immediate take on this is
a hard no yeah
especially with this online church it's
not a church she actually attends
locally
yeah so let me uh you can answer the
stock in crypto part let me answer this
um
I don't believe in treating a church
like a taco stand where you just go
sample it until like
um
when you ask yourself does this church
entertain me
what can this church do for me then
you're entering into the conversation
about church wrong
um I would ask what can I bring to this
particular group of people how can we be
with one another to help us get through
the mess that is life and not is this
person entertaining does this person
inspire me today there could be the
greatest message in the world and if
I've got
if I've got the Rockets my guts aren't
feeling good or something I gotta go to
the bathroom I'm not gonna be inspired
so that's that's a it's a faulty metric
by which to judge a church
um find a place that you want to get
invested in and just decide I'm going to
be a part of this community and of
course if there's some like something
that just violates your core values then
of course you can transition out but
it's just it's just treating uh it's
like treating churches like Netflix like
I'm just gonna scan through and find so
that's just not how you do Church yeah
the the point there is a huge part of it
is community for sure now the on the
actual stock and crypto side I'm reading
one of these articles and it's saying
long time member Tim said he and every
other members were involved in Bitcoin
realized there were considerable tax
benefits to donating some of it which
you know that's exactly why we tell
people to give to the church for the tax
benefits that's the heart that we want
and so the good news is you don't have
to give in stock in crypto you can give
them if you truly trust the leadership
team I'm huge on transparency with
church finances if I don't know where
the money's going just like a non-profit
I want to do my due diligence to make
sure the money's being used wisely and
so I love when churches are very
transparent about here's where the
money's going here's where we're
spending our money on and my problem
with doing crypto is you know if you
give in Dogecoin and then Dogecoin tanks
the next day because Elon sent a tweet
out well now the kids can't go on the
mission trip that's right so this is a
terrible stewarding of the money that
the church is being given so I don't
agree with it just on a found
foundational level of churches accepting
this it's cool that they're trying to
like meet you where you're at and be
like hey man you like Bitcoin you can
we're cool we're the cool church but no
I have not heard of this my take on it
is no and just all around no is the
final answer and I wouldn't no don't do
it I don't think my church accepts
Bitcoin and that is why I continue to go
there so you do your you do you live
your truth but I will not be donating in
Bitcoin because I want to actually see
the church do great things and I have
not seen many people do great things
through Dogecoin and fake meme coins
which they're going bankrupt and
crashing and fraud and scams everywhere
it's like the whole thing is coming
crashing down John I wonder if I'll be
able to donate the curtains that I buy
for my meta home
in the metaverse if I could donate items
used items in the metaverse to like a uh
the not real virtual fantasy that gives
me an idea for an HGTV show where they
renovate fake homes in the metaverse my
goodness this is incredible and then it
could really be it could really be one
of those moments where they have like
the young couple and they're like 24 and
like this is Dan 24 this is Susan he
dreams about websites and she mows Lawns
and their their budget they're 1.5
million Dogecoin million and they're
going to spend the most of it in in in
yes this makes me happy well hey it's an
interesting question Marge and I
appreciate you letting me know about it
all right let's go back to reality and
Eric is actually with us on a real phone
line uh in Ohio all right it's Lima
there we go Lima Ohio wonderful Eric
welcome to the show
uh thank you
um well sorry let me start over
um long time listener first time caller
I had a question about a hospital bill
all right eight month old went into the
ER my wife stayed beside my daughter the
entire time I asked for an itemized
statement because the discharge
paperwork it said that they were in
tests but they never ran tests
on itemized statement I'm getting
charged roughly about 700 for tech for
tests that were never performed is there
a chance what tests were they
um covert tests are like RSV tests and
like
other tests so sometimes trying to
figure out well sometimes tests can they
might draw one vial of blood and run
five different spins off that one vial
um or they might
um
do a quick lung listen and call that a
test
um you're gonna have a hard time
fighting that
because they get to classify what they
consider a test you and I might consider
a covet test shoving that thing up your
nose so far it comes out your feet and
all that they might consider a covet
test we did a quick a quick
um long listen and we didn't hear any
complications there so we're gonna count
that as a kova test and move on and
they're going to charge you 750 for that
code test or whatever it was
um I think you're going to be
hard-pressed
um to push back on those tasks you can
try
um You can call the call the hospital
administrator and ask for confirmation
but I think it's going to be
hard-pressed so have you gotten any
proof that they did conduct these tests
what was the read after you got the
itemized Bill and you called them back
um we called them back and they pretty
much completely dodged this subject
changed the subject they started talking
about financial aid and how I can get
financial aid to cover to help cover the
bill they just completely changed the
subject
and I mentioned about them you might
need to be the squeaky wheel and go in
person
um they've got a whole protocol for the
phones I'd go in person and sit down
with an administrator and because
they're going to treat you as though you
can't pay
and so there the you see what I'm saying
like they're trying to offload you to
these right they think you have a
question behind your question your
question is not hey you are stealing
from me you're charging me for tests you
didn't perform they think you're trying
to say hey I can't pay this bill and I'm
you're trying to take things off of the
bill and so you're it sounds like you
can you could pay the 700 bucks but this
is more about principle
it's more of a moral slash principle yes
okay I'd almost rather go into
collections for the build versus paper
or service I never
I was never received I have done that
and I ended up
um paying a bill out of collections just
so you know I made my point and then
about a year later my wife's like are
you done yet and I was like no I didn't
they didn't do it and it was a hospital
too and she's like okay
um you let me know when you're done and
then I'm gonna pay this bill I've also
played that game John it's just gonna
keep coming I'm just like you Eric I was
so angry I was like well I was there for
20 minutes how was this a 500 bill and I
have insurance this is insane and so I
called I was like I want to speak to
your supervisor I turned into a mail
Karen it was full blown it was a nasty
situation and at the end of the day they
could not and would not help me and so
at that point you just gotta go all
right I'm gonna learn my lesson here and
next time I'm gonna have to sign off on
every single thing they do and I will be
sitting there watching them that's the
big thing is this sometimes is a 700
dollar
[Music]
um lesson learned for how I'm going to
handle things next time but fight's a
good fight Eric I would be that squeaky
wheel until you can fight no more do it
in person but yeah do it in person keep
calling leave voicemails email
administrators and supervisors and vice
presidents until you get this thing
dealt with Man fight the good fight on
behalf of a broken Health Care System
everywhere that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show in the books my thanks to
all the folks in the booth keeping the
show float to my co-host Dr John deloney
and to all of you out there listening we
appreciate you we'll be back with you
before you know it
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell joined by
Dr John deloney today and we are an
excited pumped even to take your calls
about life money relationships marriage
boundaries mental health anxiety you
name it we are here for you that's right
thank you John for that poorly timed but
you know we're working on it this is a
team effort that's what my wife tells me
I'm the worst with timing it's all right
you're doing a great job thanks man I
don't know if this is therapy for you or
you're gonna actually help people today
but either way it's going to be a good
show triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the number to call and
we will get you on the lines Alex joins
us up next in Los Angeles Alex welcome
to the show
thank you very much how's it going how
are you we're doing great I'm doing I'm
doing well yeah I just started listening
not too long ago but I heard a lot of
folks with similar issues to mine and so
I thought I'd give it a call and get
scolded by Dave welcome to the club we
will be his proxy today we have taken
our share of schooling so we're happy to
pass them along what's up right on so so
um you know recently I've always kind of
been in control of my money and life and
everything but recently I guess uh you
know I got married a couple years ago
and the White Flag we bit off maybe more
than we can chew we did buy a home for
uh 590k uh it's worth you know about
eight now I use the VA loan so zero down
I rent two of the rooms out pretty much
for the last two years so house hacking
I believe is called so it has made me
money I've only paid about half the
mortgage I tried to sell the house in
June and I was on the market for like
three four months you know I stood I was
going to make about a quarter million in
uh in uh profit and um unfortunately it
didn't sell the market you know did what
it did during that time and um I I also
have a sports car it's pretty expensive
I did refinance it once and I have 18
000 in credit card debt I paid two
thousand dollars last month I expected
it would go it was 16 last month I
thought it would go down to 14 and now I
look at it in Forever it's at 8 it's 18
and I paid two thousand miles a month
well the credit card interest is insane
what's the interest on that card
um they're like 24 or something like
that that'll climb real quick
and what's left on the what's on your
car loan
so car loan has 25k left
yeah three percent
what's up what other debt do you have
uh I have the house the car and the
credit cards that's it okay
so we'll leave the house alone for now
we are focused on our steps baby step
one thousand dollar starter emergency
fund baby step two all Consumer Debt
except for the house using the debt
snowball
have you heard about those baby steps
yes I'm so more familiar with them just
from like the last month or so I've been
listening is that is that your one car
the sports car
uh we also have um like an EV that we
leased is very cheap like 230 bucks a
month wait so you have a lease as well
yes sorry that we do have the lease
that's my wife's car so that's more debt
how much is that
that one is uh it's a 230 bucks a month
about 100 bucks for insurance and like
forty dollars to charge it so relatively
cheap
okay well we call Lisa's fleeces because
there it is the most expensive way to
operate a motor vehicle
so whatever the early buyout amount on
that is I want you to do your homework
and figure that out and we're going to
throw that into the debt snowball if you
want to keep it
um you know it's it's a 27 000 I believe
is the residual value and um I could
actually sell it for about 34 000 right
now so that's what I would do just
flipping it and I'd probably also get
out of the sports car what's the sports
car worth
the sports car is worth about 55 I
bought it for 60 uh two like a year ago
you know and even with the mileage it
still held its value uh because of the
market but also because it's kind of
rare and I believe that it's it's
there's only they've only sold about 2
400 of them since uh 2017 in the US so I
do believe that it's gonna retain its
value pretty well over time as they're
going to stop making it here soon so
Alex these are not Investments yeah yeah
I'm gonna hop in here and then sorry
George I'm doing some Beautiful Mind
Math trying to help our friend Alex out
listen Alex you've got it here's what
you've got to decide you live in a
fantasy world
where money exists and it kind of
doesn't I was going to make a quarter
million dollars just didn't happen to be
there and this car is going to probably
hold its value but it's a
you can live in that world
and it's going to be chaotic and you're
going to stumble through you're going to
be married and having roommates in your
house with some sort of house hacking
scam whatever
here's the deal you can play that game
brother
the game that we play over here is I
sleep really deeply at night
and I want to laugh I laugh from my guts
because I don't owe anybody a freaking
thing nobody and I drive not a cool car
that's not holding its value because I
seriously don't care
so you see what I'm saying so we're
playing different games if you want to
play the game you're playing we're not
the right gang for you dude if you want
to have your life back we're all in
see what I'm saying I'm listening yeah
okay this is this is like a it's a
radical way to live man and what happens
is you create a halo around you your
buddies are going to want to know dude
why are you laughing all the time why
are you able to pick up the check why'd
you tip double the cost to that waitress
and you just can smile and say because I
can
right it's a totally different way of
living man
now when you called in you said I want
to be scolded like Dave would scold
which tells me that you you don't feel
like you've made wise decisions
you know yeah in this last month really
since I started listening to the show
and getting really serious you know I'm
looking at my credit card debt and I'm
like hey this is not good I've never had
this much you know I'm having trouble
paying it down
um you know I want to I want to build
wealth I don't want to lose wealth
um you know so
that was kind of the plan with selling
the house how much do you make I know
it's not I make about 140 with uh my in
my income and the the rental income and
stuff okay I'm going to walk you through
this plan real quick if I was in your
shoes today and I was fired up and I was
sick of not feeling like I was making
enough progress with my money because
you called in you said hey I feel like
I'm in control my money brother you're
not in control when you owe seven
lenders money when you put your head on
that pillow every night so here's what
I'm doing and it's radical but we're a
radical group over here so here's what
I'm going to do we are selling the
sports car you said you could sell for
55 you owe 25 that's 30k in your pocket
you said you could sell the other car
that's not the least 34 and you owe 27
that's 7K profit you tracking yep you
know thirty seven thousand dollars in
your bank account with that we're gonna
pay off the 18 000 in credit card debt
that leaves us with 19 right
yep we have no car so we're gonna go buy
a reasonable car and the rest is going
to go into our emergency fund do you
have savings right now
um not really okay well now you will and
now you become your own bank because you
don't need to turn to credit cards in
case of emergency
and you're driving a reasonable car and
while it's depreciating in value you're
not paying interest on it and you don't
need a credit card we're cutting it up
we're going to switch to a debit card
and use our own money so that we make
different decisions
but do you feel the freedom there you
can get out of this stuff tomorrow
but the question is are you actually
sick and tired of living the way you've
been living
I'm trying to play the game over here
move this card around to the zero
percent and now we're sitting here
paying 24 interest on these cards and
still feeling like we're winning
yeah so what are you are you going to
commit to this are you in yeah I
definitely I definitely think it's I
mean I've been seriously considering
selling the car even before
um we're not considering anymore today
you're talking your life going hey honey
hope you like these cars because they're
gone tomorrow hey stay on the line
brother listen stay on the line we're
gonna give you Ramsay uh we're getting a
Financial Peace University and the every
dollar app I want you guys have to watch
the video so I'm not going to give this
and just have it sit in your inbox you
got to get it watch these videos and
change your life if you don't watch it
you're going to vend mode me and John 20
bucks each all right that's the deal you
gotta have some skin in the game here
John's in
hey thanks for the call brother can't
wait for you to call back and tell us
You're Dead free this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney and we are taking your calls
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five Matt joins us up next in Sioux City
Matt welcome to the show
hey thanks guys how are you both doing
today we are doing great how can we help
hey um real quick
um just intro uh I am 27 my wife's 27 we
have a year and two months old little
girl and uh my question for the day is I
just feel really davish as of today I
don't know why it hit me so hard today
um but like my baby steps are kind of
all over the place I've got fifteen
thousand dollars left in my student
loans I went to pharmacy school
graduated a couple years ago been
putting five thousand dollars towards it
ever since I graduated each month
um but we have the 15 000 in uh a
savings account and we kind of did that
baby step obviously backwards where we
saved three to six months and that's
just been a comfortable thing to do we
said first we're going to do it when we
were having our daughter but we've kind
of kept with that
um another thing too is like with our
um way that we do checking our savings
or just seeing how we do our payments we
kind of do it retrospective instead of
actually doing like how you guys have
every dollar app like we know what's
going out but after a month has happened
we're not really you know fine-tuning
and figuring out each you know each day
kind of what we've been spending and how
we can improve on that I guess so I was
just looking for some inspiration if you
guys had some
um I Heard the Last Call there were some
a little bit of not like he wanted to
get yelled at and I kind of don't know
if I'm at that stage too actually can I
tell you can I tell you what it sounds
like
um yeah you sound exhausted
yeah a little bit today was a little bit
of a
little bit of an exhausting day which
kind of got to this point I feel like
how much the student loan most of the
pharmacy students I know graduate with a
a lot of debt how much did you graduate
with
uh 80 to 85. okay that's actually not
bad that's about a quarter of what it
usually is
um yeah you sound tired man and I am
here's you I want to free you if you
don't want to follow this plan you still
be a good guy still be a good dad still
be a good husband go about your life man
if you want to do this go all in because
you're torturing yourself in the middle
yeah
millions and millions it's not it's not
it's not hard
it's got to make choice
you can be debt-free today is that what
you're saying you'd wipe out you'd wipe
yourself out but you could be debt-free
today
yeah I could yeah why like what what is
the security blanket
um yeah that I that I can't explain well
the way the way I explained it the first
time was we had a kid coming and I
remember hearing a few times from you
know just listening to you guys that was
one where it was okay to save um we have
some older vehicles but they're working
great I love them I got a 04 Grand Am I
drove since high school and that thing's
still amazing that 03 Ford Taurus
um I don't know they're running great so
that's kind of something or if we need
to upgrade another kid potentially my
wife and I are trying to
um have another kid I don't know I guess
the unknown
um and I know that it's going to be paid
off like I said I've been doing 5 000
each month just be done man three months
from now just be done
just be done you are choosing to hang on
to a variable and as a scientist you
know the goal is to reduce the variables
get it out of the out of the picture and
then be really uncomfortable what's your
take-home salary household wise
so my wife and I this is another problem
too so I'm just being straight up with
you guys it's we get about a hundred
thousand dollars after we get retirement
out of their
um so we're taking out retirement too at
this time too oh you're investing
yeah
correct well you can continue doing that
if you pay off the debt today and also
you need to get your emergency fund back
in order so you probably need to pause
for a few months but one of the reasons
you're exhausted is because you're
running 14 different directions and
wondering why you're not getting
anywhere and then you hate yourself
every time you take another step you're
like I shouldn't have taken that step
I'll run over here and then I hate that
guy we can't sit here and inspire you to
Greatness and motivate you what we can
do is help you build a habit and build
discipline to where you're just the kind
of guy who budgets and pay pays cash for
things and who has a vision for his
future and that Vision doesn't include
paying a lender every month
so that's what we can help you do is
create a vision and help you get those
values in place versus inspiring you
with an amazing sentence like never
heard it before where you go all right
I'm all in man we can't do that in seven
minutes
no but we can pull the rubber band back
and cause you to feel that pain what's
been inspiring about go ahead Jordan I'm
sorry no it's all good
what's been inspiring I was just gonna
say what's been inspiring is like
listening to like George here and you
paying off your house like I that's like
been one that stuck with me for a long
time
um and that's what I'm excited to do I
want to get this debt done and I next up
to that is
hold on you don't want to you want to
want to no I want to you don't want to
because if you did like you'd be debt
free you'd be debt free already yeah
something is keeping you from doing it
so make the choice man
yeah here's the thing yeah you're right
most people don't realize that they are
already in the ring they think they can
avoid the fight that is being an adult
and what happens is you are just saying
like I don't want to fight and the world
just starts throwing punches at you
at some point you either tap out which
is fine I quit cool or you have to swing
back
and you're trying to pretend like you're
not in a fight and you are
you could be debt-free today the wants
you have the inspiration the George
inspired me dude by the way
um like so I get that I get where your
heart's at he's got to choose
yeah one of the best things we did is to
decide that our plan wasn't working and
that's a really hard pill to swallow
because you got to swallow your pride
and go dang it I thought I could
outsmart the system and so when we
decided to do this plan we just decided
it was we pre-decided that we were going
to go all in on this plan that Davis
wasn't going to get us to where we
wanted to go fast enough and when you go
all in and your wife is on the plan too
which means we got to get to the root of
maybe that security gland that was going
hey we really need an emergency fund
before we start paying off this debt and
we really should be investing because
that's a wise thing to do those things
are all great but the problem is when
you do them all at once you don't feel
the progress and so the great news is
you can make a different decision today
right now
yep and it's scary you're right but you
have to choose do you do you want to be
comfortable because that's what you
mentioned well just more comfortable to
have the emergency fund wow we owe under
15 000 Comfort to me is freedom and the
way you do that is by not owing anyone
anything and you have a great income we
can pause investing you're gonna get the
emergency fund way faster in place if we
stop the investing and stop messing
around which is going to create a real
sense of security because right now you
have a false sense of it and you're 27
and for whatever it's worth George and I
always say like sometimes the best
advice we can give you is this is what
we did in our house there's been several
times in my adult life my wife and I
have paused investing to meet a
financial goal for a short period of
time couple years here six months here
and so I'm just telling you what I do in
my own house to get ahead
and you're you're way younger than me
man
yeah
I mean I like I said that that was
enough though what you guys said too I
sometimes you just gotta need to hear
from people that have done it and I know
I know you guys have done it I've
listened enough to you guys but it you
know I it's it's something that I don't
know what it is it's maybe something for
you John to talk about more further if
you guys want to but Davis missed just
regarding even money and stuff too like
my faith I'm sometimes Davis I just feel
like maybe I'm hard on myself for being
Davis in many aspects of life but that
shouldn't stop me from actually doing
what I need to do you know well at some
point if you start to see some recurring
patterns in your life that are
disruptive
do the most the boldest bravest thing
you can do and go talk to somebody
yeah I've done that when I when the
color in the world starts to turn down
on me
and
um I reach out and I either have a group
of friends group of men in my life that
I trust I'm like dude I I'm starting to
slide and they'll say hey we'll come
over we're grabbing dinner we're going
out tonight to hang out or I could see a
therapist man I've got a coach that I
work with once a week like I have to
surround myself with other people that
say Hey it feels like the color's
draining out of your life it's not look
how bright that is there's Beauty over
here there's joy over here and by the
way go work out go exercise get this
crap paid off and so it's both in right
but go call somebody man you know what
to do man now the decision is yours are
you gonna do it or do you want to
continue living the way you've been
living either way we're cheering you on
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsay show the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five I'm George
Campbell joined by Dr John deloney today
and we're taking your calls Brian joins
us up next in Atlanta Georgia Brian
welcome to the show
hey guys I really appreciate you taking
my call and by the way you guys are
doing a really great job I'm enjoying
listening to you thanks Brian we're the
dream team that's right yeah
so what's up man
so my wife and I are not necessarily
having a disagreement we're we're in a
fortunately a good situation where we're
we're selling our house and historically
we've been really good on tithing for
you know standard income
uh where we're having a disagreement is
I think we ought to use the money that
we're making off the home that we're
netting and tithe that money like we
would if it was normal income and she
just disagrees with me she's looking at
this as just money we could put away and
I'm like well we will but I'm looking at
it as normal income that we should tie
that I we our agreement is well whatever
you guys say is pretty much what we'll
do because we've always listened to you
and you've felt this out to this point
so
so anytime a husband tells me we're not
really having a disagreement y'all are
in like really like she's holding a
knife you've yeah you've got like a
stick of wood listen I married up I've
got the best life in the world she's
she's awesome all right so yeah
is she there Brian
yes he is she's I got you on my cell
phone and she's uh right next to me wow
well do we want to hear from her
do you want to hear her side of the coin
here
it may help
no she doesn't want to talk okay that's
fine too now I don't know that you know
the finer you look into the fine print
of this the less it feels generous if
we're like splitting hairs over it so I
don't think there's a a Biblical mandate
on the sales of homes and profits on
that so let's get into the numbers here
how much did you buy the home for how
much are you selling for
well we're netting about a little over
four hundred thousand so we sold it for
650 we owed 200 on it so after
commissions and everything I'm
estimating a little bit over 400 000
will walk away would you buy it yeah uh
265. okay and you're selling it for how
much
650. way to go first of all when did you
buy this house
uh about 15 years ago well done and is
this after all expenses
realtor fees you name it you're going to
be netting how much somewhere north of
400. exactly okay
way to go so you are in the boat of you
don't think this needs to be tithed on
and she's like I think we should
opposite opposite you think you should
write a 40 000 check to your church she
thinks you should take that money and
put it in the account what are you guys
doing next
we are moving into an apartment uh that
we a mixed-use community that we love to
be in uh it's like it has retail
restaurants so we're gonna we're gonna
live there for a year or two and enjoy
living in an apartment and an area that
we know that we enjoy while we uh try to
find our forever home for lack of a
better term Brian what's it like being
married to a woman when you're so much
of a better Christian than she is
yeah I mean you can look at you can
parse scriptures and go to Deuteronomy
you know 14 22 says fully tithe all the
increase of your grain that the field
produces year by year so we would say
all right if you want to do it do it off
of the actual net profit after all
expenses and if you want to consider
this income because you have an extra
400 000 that you didn't before and you
want to tithe on that I think you guys
are going to be fine either way will it
hurt yeah maybe yeah but maybe that's
good for you to realize you know this
wasn't my money to begin with it's never
been easy because I I'm in sales and I'm
I make just 100 commission and I've done
very very well I think thank you to you
guys in the Lord but I I so when we're
writing a check a lot of times it is ten
twenty thirty thousand dollars and it's
never been easy because you can find a
lot of things to do with that money
but we historically have been
disciplined we we have we've done it and
uh for some reason she's looking at this
as maybe the exception
I I for me it comes down to one thing
and that is um who do you and your wife
as a couple who do you all believe
actually owns the money
yeah not us and if that's the sentiment
then this idea that then you're just
stewarding something that's not yours
um that's a different proposition then
I'm giving 30 000 of my dollars to a
thing right
um it's just it's just a difference in
how you're going to hold your hands how
tight you're tightly you're going to
hold your hands I don't believe like
scripture I don't I don't believe
there's a I don't know maybe I get
struck by lightning here I don't believe
there's a right or wrong here I think
it's what this is not a Salvation issue
you and your church have agreed to what
is in your heart and are you going to
violate your own conscience on this deal
yeah I don't think you're getting to the
Pearly Gates and the angels are like hey
hey pay up dude 40 Grand Where's My
Money where's my money but I do think
there's a there's Amazing Power uh while
you're here on Earth of what that will
do for your spirit as a reminder so I'm
not saying she's right and you're wrong
I think you need to come to an agreement
on it's a hard issue and what feels good
for you guys and what are you not going
to lose sleep over
and if you're going to roll all this
into equity and buy a new home I go okay
I mean this is going towards the next
thing this is not just freed up money
that's going to be sitting out there but
if you're gonna go live in an apartment
and this is just truly increase and you
want to tithe on that or she wants to
tithe on that
um I think it's the wise thing to do and
I think if you look across the board
here if you lined up me and George and
Dave and Ken Coleman and Rachel Cruz and
Christina probably all of us would do a
version of something a little bit
different or maybe a few would do this
way do it this way and so I just don't
want to get hung up on the legalism of
it and I particularly don't want there
to be a rift in my marriage over it yeah
being unified in it and if in the end of
the day your wife says I think that what
we're doing is wrong I think this money
is is for us to build our home and fill
the blank and you can find peace in that
man high five you and if she says you
know what if it's if you're that
convicted if you're forty thousand
dollars convicted this is the right
thing to do I'm going to go with you on
this great man great
you sound like you are going to lose
more sleep by not giving than she will
yes by giving it'll gnaw at me yeah that
to me would be The Driver um the times
in my life when I haven't listened to
that inner growling it's it's almost
always been a mistake
yeah
well she wants me to ask y'all one more
question if you don't mind sure
so we both drive very old kids we've
never been big on vehicles
um we were planning on buying two new
vehicles not with the sale of the house
money but I'm having a very good year in
sales
and paying cash uh one for her and one
for me but it's going to be probably if
you add everything up about 160 000 for
the two vehicle whoa y'all are screwing
around I know Joe dude from Kia to Tesla
how do you draw the line on you know the
amount that you pay for cars versus the
income you make
well we say we don't want you to have
more than 50 percent of your income tied
up and things with motors in them and
also we don't want you buying brand new
cars unless you're net worth
millionaires it sounds like you guys are
net worth millionaires we are okay so
I'm not mad at that what's your
household income
um after this year probably 1.5
1.5 cars dude and we're fighting over 40
Grand the phone uh Brian get off the go
buy her a 40 000 watch and I mean good
grave
yes you're good go by hey you will make
40 Grand this month let me be honest
with you Brian so this is hard for me
and Dave actually walked me through this
um
personally off air I get that benefit by
sitting next to him at some point when
you have grown up without a lot and it's
those people who have that kind of money
and those people who drive those cars
sometimes these purchases you have to
look at them as the ratios
because you can spend a hundred and
sixty thousand dollars on cars and
that's the equivalent of me spending
five hundred dollars on cars when when
you look at my overall net worth and if
you've given away 200 300 400 000 if you
are that generous spirit and you this
rests well with your conscience because
it clearly works well financially to buy
your cars if you make one and a half
million and you spend 150 Grand on cars
that's ten percent that's like someone
just makes 40 Grand spending four grand
on four thousand dollars we would say
that's very reasonable yeah so you guys
have done really well now knowing that I
don't know why we were
jumping at the bit over a 40 Grand
checkup next time you ask a financial
question lead with I'm gonna make one
and a half million dollars this year
historical information Brian but way to
go you guys have great hearts and uh the
Lord has blessed you man love to hear
that this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so a few days ago we were in lovely
Phoenix Arizona for two completely sold
out events on our Building Wealth tour
and the energy in the room both nights
was absolutely incredible so if you've
been thinking about joining us stop
thinking do it don't miss your chance
the events in Sacramento and San Antonio
are completely sold out already we have
a few seats left for Building Wealth
Minneapolis on November 10th so if you
want tickets to see us in Minneapolis
you gotta buy them now because for sure
this one's going to sell out too prices
go up this Friday for the Minneapolis
event so get the early bird discount
before it's too late it's going to be
Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney
Ken Coleman and myself will be talking
about Building Wealth in this current
economy and show you how you can get on
the path to building real lasting wealth
so we already did Phoenix Sacramento's
on November 1st that sold out
Minneapolis November 10th a few tickets
left there San Antonio to end it out on
November 15th that one sold out tickets
start at just 25 bucks or you can get a
four pack starting at 60 which is 15
bucks a pop that's an amazing deal
go to ramseysolutions.com events to
reserve your seats now looking forward
to get to getting back on the road with
you John dude Phoenix was a blast we ate
some good tacos too crush some tacos
why so much queso before the event that
was a bold move on your part hey dude uh
if you can put me on torches okay so
good things happen can do some damage I
love it let's go to the phones the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five Charlie joins us
in Dallas Texas Charlie welcome to the
show
hello thanks for uh taking my call sure
how can we help
um I am about 135 000 that
um
85 000 of it is about student loans and
then I got two cars
my wife makes about 2 000 a month and I
make
anywhere from 38 to six thousand dollars
a month
and I do not know how to get us out of
debt
well I'm glad you called us man are you
a new listener how long you been
listening to the show
um on and off for a few years but
religiously for the last three weeks so
what made you call us today versus three
years ago
tired of not being able to sleep ah
there you go that's a good place to be
and it's a bad place to be but it's good
because you're ready to get out aren't
you and you're willing to do whatever it
takes now
yes and you guys are bringing home
anywhere from six to eight k a month
total
yes okay that's good news
now these car loans what are the cars
worth
um one of them is worth five thousand
and I owe eight thousand and the other
one's worth probably 12 and I owe I
think 18 000 on it so you're underwater
on both of these things
yes
okay
well how much money do you have saved in
the bank
uh zero
how little can you live on out of that
six to eight thousand a month what are
your actual expenses
uh
we I've listed up and I believe it's
about
five thousand
you have 5 000 in expenses
yes do you guys own a home in what
um we owe we pay 1500 a month in our
rent and then one car's 500 the other
car is 280 our utilities are about 250 a
month cell phones we pay almost 400 a
month 400 for cell phones
uh for four of us yes wow you guys are
getting ripped off man big time
uh that's T-Mobile for you
no that's way too much that is not
T-Mobile's fault that's you you they can
charge whatever they want to charge you
signed up for it man
yeah okay so you're A1 I'm gonna get you
on an every dollar budget and I'm gonna
gift you the premium version for a year
if you're willing to do it
thank you but here's what that means you
are going to track every transaction
like a madman and before you make any
decision you're gonna ask yourself does
this help me become debt free and find
the freedom that I've desperately been
looking for
okay and when you do that here's what
you're going to do you're going to go
why are we paying 400 bucks we got to
find a better deal we're switching cell
phone companies today who are the four
people in your family
um my two kids my wife and I how old are
the kids
16 and 13. they can participate
they can get jobs and help out with a
hundred dollar a month cell phone bill
good God almighty all right I'm gonna
also gift you Financial Peace University
is your wife on board with this or is it
just you yes she is she's fully
yes okay we need to find out where all
this 8 000 is going because you're
telling me even if your expenses are
five you have an extra three to throw at
the debt
yes can you work overtime where's the
variable pay come in
um I'm an independent contractor
um I usually work
10 hours a day
um 10 to 12 about six days a week and
what is your wife doing for work
um she is she works for the school
district
okay hold on hold on you're an
independent contractor
you're an independent contractor working
10 hour day six days a week and you make
about 70 000 bucks a year
yes you need to find another job you're
either not doing very well as an
independent contractor
or you are being dramatically underpaid
but you are killing yourself for seventy
thousand bucks
you can go drive a truck for what for
that that annual amount of money
okay you see what I'm saying what do you
do like the the general contractors if I
can get one to call me back right now
for work at my house that I'll pay with
cash there I mean it's a premium for the
for the privilege of coming out to my
house just to look at it
are you not charging enough
um I work a delivery service so it uh I
get paid by what they offer for the
delivery
okay
do you like this work
yes and it works with our scheduling of
everything that we've got going on okay
George is walking you through this
there's only two things you can do with
money you can cut expenses or you can
make more of it
okay and I want you to do both yeah if
this job is taking your like it takes
every last hour of your life and that's
what it gets you it might be working for
your family schedule wise but it might
make paying this dead off take five
years instead of three or six years
instead of two
so it might work for you every week it
might not work for you long term okay
okay now you said you were 135 in in
debt but the numbers aren't quite adding
up because you said you had 85 and
student loans and two car loans but the
two car loans don't add up to 50K
and then we have uh two uh loans we took
out and then which
I think we are about 800 left on it we
have three credit cards
and then uh our medical debt that we
have
how old is the medical debt
um
anywhere from 10 years to just recent
okay you need to call and negotiate that
today
but you need to scrape together some
money to throw at it how much is the
total medical debt
um last time I looked I think we owed
like
13 000 total okay you're gonna need to
scrape together maybe four or five
thousand and call them and say listen I
can pay you four or five thousand if you
call it good and settle in full and then
writing
and beyond that we're going to pay off
the smallest to largest regardless of
interest rates and start attacking this
debt if that means you need a personal
loan because you're underwater on the
cars to get out of these and get two
really cheap beater cars to get you
around to speed this up I'm okay with
that but we've got to start making some
drastic decisions so if we want to see
progress
and that means maybe your wife is going
to find a different job because she's
getting paid minimum wage working for
the school district
right
yeah you don't seem to like our answers
no no uh it's good advice
it's okay if you don't you're a grown
man you can you can do whatever you want
to it's just I don't think you recognize
how radical you got to get to pay this
135 000 off
it's gonna take some work man hang on
the line Austin's gonna pick up we're
gonna gift you FPU and every dollar and
I'm gonna give you four tickets to our
smart conference event in Dallas and I
want to see you when we come out during
the breaks I want to see Charlie from
Dallas say dude I'm all in this event is
part of that Journey my wife is here my
kids are here we are all in on this
thing so hang on the line we're gonna
get you the whole kitten caboodle to get
you on this journey but you've got to
want it more than we do man this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
co-host of the Ramsey show did you know
over 18 million
people the Ramsey Show
a lot of those people live
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell joined today by my colleague
and friend Dr John deloney and we are
taking your calls this hour at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Susan is kicking us off in Des Moines
Susan welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call happy to
take it what's going on hey so I'm
watching about the um the current
hurricane that's heading towards Florida
and yeah I live in Iowa so we get lots
of tornadoes here and I was thinking if
um something wiped out the power in this
area a big natural disaster and I didn't
have access to my emergency funds how
much cash should I have on hand just in
case hmm
interesting question how much do you
have in your emergency fund right now
I have over a thousand dollars right now
okay what baby step are you in have you
been following the plan I've been
following the plan yeah so
um uh I want to say like two and a half
to three so you still have some debt
I do still have some debt that I'm down
to less than 15 of My overall available
okay how much debt do you have left
okay
and then a thousand in the bank
yeah cool all right well I mean I'm not
counting my mortgage in that 15 sure
that's your Consumer Debt
yeah okay well you called the right show
at the right time because I have the
prepper himself Dr John deloney this man
has enough deep freezers to last a
century yeah I'm more into
um
uh
food and things like that more than I'm
cash so
um hey this is actually a like I grew up
in Houston so very similar tornadoes and
hurricanes all the time just kind of a
part of life
um so I'm gonna tell you what I think
I'm gonna tell you what my reality is is
that cool
yeah
um what I think is a small amount of
cash that it which that number is going
to be relative to people what I consider
a small amount of cash and what Dave
Ramsey considers a small amount of cash
very different numbers all right
um but
what would I what would I need to give
me a couple of days if I needed to go
stay in a hotel if I need to leave town
and drive a couple hours away and put
gas in the car like very basic if I need
to go get some food and groceries and I
didn't have access to a b or c
um it's balancing this what could happen
with like what's probably gonna happen
right and as a the son of a homicide
detective I was raised to believe it
could all come down at any moment
because that was that was my dad's world
and so that's my natural bent and I've
had to train myself over the years too
it could but it probably will right it
probably won't so I have no problem if
you have a thousand dollars in emergency
fund that you keep 250 500 bucks at home
um in cash just as a I can go get a
hotel and I can drive somewhere and be
somewhere for a couple hours or I could
drive 24 hours and get out of here and
go stay with a friend right that's what
we're looking for
um
the idea that if the whole banking
system goes down the the cash is worth
the paper it's printed on right so right
um we tend to overdraw we tend to
pretend that the world after some kind
of crazy Calamity that the world would
exist as it does and I have a friend
who's a banker and he's like dude if the
whole world goes down you're going to be
shooting your neighbor for water and
barbecuing dog like like the world as
you know it is over right so it's not
like my cash is going to help here's the
other side
um I am I don't say I'm a prepper I'm
just someone who's prepared how about
that sure that's literally a different
verb um yeah I'm but
um I live in the woods and I have a
Year's worth of meat on hand right now
that's right so I some would call me a
Georgia call me a prepper I live in a
neighborhood in a society it's a little
different exactly but there is wisdom
and what Johnson but I don't have any
cash at my house right now I don't have
five thousand dollars hidden at home I
have I've done that before I don't have
that right now
um I'm not super concerned about it
okay there's a spectrum from like a
tornado maybe coming versus like it's
the apocalypse which I've seen Left
Behind very scary anytime I see a pile
of clothes I'm nervous I'm like did I
get is this it is it happening it's gone
but Susan I think it's wise if you have
a thousand bucks right now in the bank
if you want to take out 500 of that in
cash and put it in a fireproof safe I
think there's some wisdom that's gonna
help you sleep cool yeah but I also
wouldn't go yeah once you're out of debt
and you will fully funded what you guys
thought yeah once you get like 10 000 in
the bank maybe you up it to a thousand
in that safe to having cash just in case
even Beyond a natural disaster sometimes
you just need to have cash on hand uh
your bank accounts got locked up for
some reason yeah there's wisdom in that
during the tornado that came through
Nashville here um I don't know when the
last time you were in like a an event
where power went out for a couple of
days or something like that but I was
stunned at how fast technology has
shifted people were able to buy things I
was able to buy something with my debit
card on somebody's cell phone because
they had one of those little plug-in
things it just they it went very very
quickly is what I'm saying so that I
like I grew up one time when Hurricane
Alicia came through we had nothing for
like 10 days like nothing we cooked on a
camp stove it was the whole deal
um
in some parts of the world that still
happens in some parts of our country
that still happens it's very very rare
do you feel better Susan
I do I just you know like I've got my
dry food and my water and blankets and
whatever else and I was just thinking
wow I don't have any money am I going to
need to put some of that aside so I
wanted to know what your thoughts were
on it in my life the more cash I have at
my house the more money I spend on stuff
that I really don't need that's that's
that's it's a it's a self-control
mechanism that's why I like keeping it
in the fireproof safe not just gonna sit
in the wallet John that's how it
disappears but this is a real John
regardless of what the reason is natural
disaster or something else there's a lot
of fear like I get messages probably at
least once a week if someone going but I
was watching the news and what if and
what if the digital money and currency
goes digital and I I saw what if Biden
and the IRS is going to start looking at
our and it just spirals out of control
and usually they don't say I'm looking
at the news I just say hey turn off the
news turn it off and I go yeah you're
right
um I I've told it on this show but a
buddy of mine who's
um he's a banking commissioner and he's
he's just a brilliant line when it comes
to money I was hammering them one time
just what about this and what about this
and I was in one of my anxiety spirals
it's all coming down and he finally said
the magic words that was like a light
switch for me and he looked at me and
said hey John I don't have a meteorite
plan
and I was like what's that supposed to
mean he goes I'm gonna put money in
retirement I'm gonna put money in this
in this program I'm gonna pay my house
off I don't owe anybody on cars because
they're depreciating assets and it's
dumb to borrow money under he just he's
just so so straightforward as a banker
and then he goes and then if I get hit
by a meteorite I'm gonna deal with that
on that day because I'm just not gonna
just waste and I was like oh yeah
so if all the monetary system implodes
and crashes we have bigger issues
there'll be much better that's exactly
right
um that at that point you know it's
going to be your best bet your best
apocalypse bet what's that have close
relationships with your neighbors
know your neighbors so that they don't
look at you as an enemy they look at you
as somebody to do life with and to get
through the next hurdle hurdles that
y'all gonna have to overcome together
know your neighbors really really well
that's your best apocalyptic move that's
good not having a bunch of
cryptocurrency they're not gonna want
that the apocalypse they are the zombies
cannot be bought my neighbors Gary and
Lon they're not going to be doing much
with Dogecoin nope but they will bring
tomatoes sugar my neighbor gave me some
tomatoes from his garden the other day
of that we can do it this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you know it's crazy the Ramsey show has
been around for 30 years and to
celebrate we recorded a video panel with
all of the Ramsey Show co-hosts in one
room to take a look back at some of the
unbelievable experiences we've had over
the years especially Dave who has been
there for all 30 of them so in my
favorite episode we talk about the best
and worst calls we've taken and there
have been some doozies so we laugh at
some old audio of Dave's thick Southern
drawl in those early years you got to
hear that and we remember some of the
most gut-wrenching inspiring and even
bizarre moments on the show and producer
James produced this panel and you're
gonna love it we brought in the actual
calls and audio clips from all of those
and definitely my favorite episode we
also talk about where we see the show
going in the next 30 Years you can find
all four of these special episodes on
our YouTube channel filled with stories
from three decades of amazing people
doing amazing things to change their
lives and live like no one else so go
check out the Ramsay show on YouTube and
watch the 30th Anniversary panel that
dropped last week open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five I'm George Campbell joined today by
Dr John deloney and Chad joins us up
next in San Antonio Chad welcome to the
show
hey guys thank you very much I
appreciate it sure how can we help my
question today is
I'm not having a disagreement at all
with my wife but I'm just thinking about
this and what is your thoughts on it
it's quite the disclaimer I believe you
go ahead no really
um she's wanting to buy a investment
property to use it as a rental on the
coast why I don't have a problem with
that why uh to invest money and get a
little bit now where did you hear about
this
she saw it like an Instagram video or a
tick tock or something
we actually have a place down there
already a vacation home of our own and
it's a new development that's coming
about okay and it seems like a pretty
good deal my question to you or your
thoughts I'm guessing is
they're they're saying that we can
Finance with them whatever and they
would lock Us in but if it won't go
higher than seven percent so my question
is I'm not scared of an investment I'm
not scared of putting it in real estate
but do I put more money down do I walk
away from it completely
I just kind of wanted to get your
thoughts there I'm not out of debt I I
do owe money on my home which I owe
roughly 250 on my property and it's
worth north of Amelia other than that
I'm debt free so no Consumer Debt just a
mortgage on your personal
that is correct okay
well we would tell you to pay off your
primary residence first and then pay for
any investment property in cash
and that is super conservative and super
not cool in today's culture because you
know what that means you're like that's
like six ten years from now boring I
want the money now the problem is you're
gonna go you're gonna be over a half
million dollars in debt how much is this
new property
roughly 400. do you owe on your other
beach house
no it's paid for okay
and how often are you going to this
beach house
uh twice a month at least oh nice do you
rent it out in between or is this just
for you guys
personal use only okay
well you got the paid for rental house
what's that worth or the vacation
property
um 150 it's worth 150. okay and you owe
250 what's your income
uh combined we're this year is going to
be probably three and a quarter way to
go
fantastic income so the question is
making three and a quarter how quickly
could we pay off 250 and then save up
another 400.
yeah so that's 650. you guys make 325 a
year how much of that can go towards
these uh these exciting dreams you have
well I've got I've got some I got enough
to pay off my home in the bank
oh and it's one of those scary things I
was listening to the last caller you
talked about Doomsday Preppers and my
wife's like well I'd rather keep it in
the bank where we know where it's at how
much money do you have in the bank
roughly 370. why Chad dude why what are
you doing man
how should I invest it you should pay
your house off
that the the the your you have a tax
every month we can just call it your
prepper tax
which is the APR on your home
you are paying you are paying every
month to not pay your house off
like in in a in a major event
not owing anybody anything
and being out of work let's say covet
hits again and everybody can't go to
work for 70 or 60 days or 120 days or
whatever and the country's broke it is
and they can't just mail checks anymore
the person who doesn't owe anybody
anything is going to be better off than
the person who suddenly can't make any
payments is that fair
yes so having 370 thousand dollars in
the bank in your bank while you're
paying somebody else interest on money
they've they just it just clinically
insane it doesn't make any it doesn't
make any sense if you had twenty five
thousand dollars in cash on top of your
emergency fund just as an extra like oh
man just in case I could go with you
there I'm enough of a prepper to get
that are you 25 000 bucks under your
mattress gotcha I'm with you on that but
dude
pay your house off me pay your house off
man and the the idea of having this
rental house with a mortgage on it means
your profits are going to be real Slim
which means you're better off making
your 325 than you are making a thousand
dollars if you're lucky in profits on
this rental house
making 12 a year right yes so walk out
the scenario with me you have 370 at the
bank we pay off the house today that
leaves you with 120. let's call 20 of
that your emergency fund that leaves you
with a hundred right
yes the the rental property you want is
400 which means you have a 300 000 Gap
you make 325. could you save three
hundred thousand dollars in less than
two years making 325 with no payments in
the world say yes
so now we're looking at this with a very
different lens you called in saying I'm
concerned about interest rates now we're
not concerned about anything and by the
way if you have if we have six to seven
percent interest rates which is what
buying a house is right now
um
if you in the house cost 400 Grand if
you show up to that scenario with 375
000 in cash and say I'll buy it right
now they'll sell it to you
and wealthy people with cash don't care
about interest rates because it it
doesn't apply to them
it applies to people who are who are
having to work through a bank to make
their day a little bit brighter you see
how you just opt out of the whole system
this way
yes and that's how the wealthy hang on
to their money because they have cash
when other people are having to scramble
to and the the market slows down because
of interest rates the wealthy can come
in and buy stuff with cash at much
cheaper prices and that's how the
wealthy get wealthier
a lot of gosh so it sounds like we're a
year and a half away from getting a
rental house Chad the twitch make you
sad
no it doesn't are you going to pay off
your house today please say yes that
would be so cool for a guy that hasn't
paid off his house yet do it for me man
do it for John
I'm not going to do anything without
talking all right I know better than
that that was a trap you passed the test
well played pay your house off man this
is a different conversation now for Chad
he gets to go to his wife and say honey
we're gonna get that rental house but
it's gonna take a little while yes give
us 18 months and that means we're paying
off the house today that frees us up
completely we have a hundred thousand in
the bank still towards this house and we
make 325 we can put away 150 to 200
every year which means we're going to
have this money within the next 18
months a lot and we're not going to owe
anything which means every single dime
that comes in is now profits yes after
our expensive our after our expenses and
that to me man there's such freedom in
that I remember
um and again I don't buy into all of the
investment strategies but I remember a
conversation with Charlie Munger and
Warren Buffett and they said what's the
number one strategy for invest like
what's the number one thing I could do
for investing
and I think it was Charlie Munger that
said have 10 million dollars in your
checking account
because you never know and be able to be
the first guy at the table with a check
and say I'll buy that right now and you
will get an extraordinary deal from
somebody who needs to sell something
you'll give them a gift of getting rid
of the thing you'll get an incredible
deal and you don't have to go to a bank
or raise money or whatever have 10
million dollars in your checking account
I'm a long way I've got ten dollars on
my checking account but this idea that
dude interest rates don't apply to you
if you're paying with cash you don't
have to worry about what the economy is
doing you just get a giant pile of money
that's right that's good problem to have
but Chad's done a great job man we are
cheering you on excited for this rental
house in the near future this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined today by Dr John
deloney
wanted to remind you guys that if you
enjoy this show please consider
subscribing leaving us five stars
leaving reviews and sharing it with your
friends if this show has helped you in
any way we wanted to help more people
like you that would be fantastic open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Jenny joins us up next
in NYC Jenny welcome to the show
hi guys thank you for kicking the call
absolutely how can John and I help
okay so we owe a hundred and seventeen
thousand dollars
and that mostly Consumer Debt 20 000 of
those are to the IRS we are already on
payment times with the IRS that's the
first thing we did when we found out
with Rio the money
we've made every stupid financial
decision possible with NATO
and um welcome to the club
I am expecting a child in two months I
am currently working remotely I have one
child in school and one with me while I
work remotely and we can choose money
I thought we were leaving within our
means we thought we were doing
everything we had to do until I noticed
that all of our credit cards were maxing
out and I'm like how is this possible no
we can't do that I did a detailed budget
and we had a 1100 deficit on a monthly
basis
and we've been doing that for the past
almost a year
that's how you go into 117 000 in debt
for sure yes and not only that we
purchased a home we bought the least
expensive home that we can purchase in
the New York City area New Jersey area
and
um once you open one wall that you think
oh there's five thousand lemons that I
have been saved up will help us do this
one wall once you open that one will you
realize that you just
um it was a money pit and we've spent
over a hundred thousand dollars fixing
so that's where most of our Consumer
Debt comes from it's us putting stuff on
the credit cards to fix the house
because once one thing was fixed 20
other things were broken and then we
have car issues we don't have any car
payments or cards really old and has
been paid for but like I said everything
else it's um a lot of consumer that now
coin we fill it out and I've been
listening to you guys for the past three
weeks since we started our budget I'm
I'm angry I'm mad I don't know what else
to do and I am every feeling in between
to get me started and motivated to just
do it my husband has been able to pick
up
12 extra hours in overtime at work
but just to commute to work it cost us
around twelve hundred dollars a month
between tolls and gas
we are about two hours away from where
we live
and taking public transportation is
going to be a six hour commute three
going and three coming back what's he
doing for work
the state
so he is um he helped with the audit of
um the documents that are needed for
that
hey Jenny I'm going to ask you a hard
question okay and I'm I normally make
jokes about this that I'm not playing
okay I'm being I hear it in your voice
okay you're a scared
um mother of young kids with another one
on the way okay I hear it in you
um
there is something and people can roll
their eyes and I get that and it's worth
rolling your eyes at but if you if
you're born and raised in Texas and
you're born and raised in New York
there's an extra you can't leave
right are you connected to New York
yes and well we have our employment or
our
vet to one of them taking one of that we
actually move to the next state closer
just because we couldn't afford living
in New York anymore no I'm talking about
cut ties completely and go to another
state where you can keep your income
your state income tax where you can get
some some breath in your life you've
created a life for yourself that your
bodies cannot exist in
you cannot commute six hours a day and
be parents and be married and be
connected to one another you just can't
you can't have this you can't have run a
deficit of eleven hundred dollars twelve
hundred of that is just in taxes and in
tolls and in gas commuting you see I'm
like you've created a life that you
can't exist in and it may be that the
Northeast isn't the place for you and
your family right now
is that an option for you cut ties with
this house You've Lost Your you've lost
it it's fine can we go somewhere and
start over because this isn't working
man you're drowning
it is we are so um we are drowning and
we made it to the point where we are now
at a 700 per place with the overtime
that we're going to be doing I know but
that's I know hun but that's temporary
yeah you're working overtime you're
commuting all over the place your your
cars are falling apart right you see
there's so much these are Band-Aids
am I right if I'm wrong tell me but it
sounds like I'm right you're right
the extra 700 throwing at 117 000 it is
a never-ending battle at that point and
so we're trying to find any way you can
drastically reduce expenses and increase
or keep your income and that might mean
making some big sacrifices that you
don't want to do right now
yeah what's your mortgage payment
uh 2400. what's your take-home pay
clean after everything at 6200.
if you
are you is a house in sellable condition
could you sell it and not lose your
backside I won't be able to lose after
everything we've invested in the house
was
y'all would do okay
no we would not oh you would
it would be a loss yes could you sell it
um take out what you've invested in it
versus what you owe could you get out
clean
what's it worth and what's left on the
mortgage
um we gave a 20 down the houses was
what we purchased it at right now 465.
um and what's your mortgage
so we get 20 down so whatever that was
90 something thousand dollars okay
that's all that has been paid in the
house we've invested over a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars in payment and
you get your 20 back but you're still in
the hole because of all the six figures
you invested into it
but that's called sunk cost fallacy you
may never get that money back yes so
that may be the biggest stupid tax you
pay in your life but the problem I'm
seeing right now is that forty percent
of your take-home pay is going towards
the mortgage
yes and that's before the tolls and the
gas and the kids and so right now you
can't breathe
so this isn't a sustainable lifestyle to
begin with even with the extra 700
coming in
okay so I I
this is really hard because it's one of
those things that we're like sincerely
we're afraid of the unknown I don't
think we'll be able to make what we make
now in another state
and we'll still have a hundred and
seventeen thousand dollars in debt in
another state
I wouldn't put that out into the world
um you you work remote correct could you
move out of New York
um we're doing me a favor because I am a
high risk pregnancy
required in the office what do you make
annually
I make 70 000 members doing what I'm an
HR analyst you absolutely can make
seventy thousand dollars outside of New
York
and if you make sixty thousand dollars
in the state of Tennessee you keep a
chunk of that money because there's no
state income tax
and you can make sixty thousand dollars
being a math teacher in the right School
District so here's what I'm saying I
don't want you to limit yourself on
Fantasy on imagination because y'all are
in desperate need of data of facts and
your husband what does he do at the
airport
a few years
he is okay I travel all over the country
so does George we've been to a lot of
airports they need a lot of coordination
across across the country okay and I bet
he could coordinate all kinds of
different things here's what I'm saying
you'll have to get real about the fact
that you'll have created a life for
yourselves that is not sustainable you
cannot live in the Life you've created
whether that means move whether that
means different jobs or that means sell
your house and yes you're going to eat a
hundred thousand dollars you put into it
that stinks but you can get out even
Steven rent for a couple of years move
to Kansas move to Texas I don't care
what you do but I want you to imagine a
life where you've got peace and you got
to build from there
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
Deuteronomy 31 6 be strong and
courageous do not be afraid or terrified
because of them for the Lord your God
goes with you you will never leave you
nor forsake you
Switching gears Jackie Chan once said
wow what a pivot that was he said don't
wait for the change of circumstances you
change the circumstances that's a good
one in other news that was just didn't
expect it Austin Well Done George is the
king the king of the transition a lot of
wisdom in both of those quotes Timeless
and modern there we go all right open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Wills up next in
Columbia South Carolina will welcome to
the show
thanks man that was a uh that was a hard
left turn I agreed it's hard to follow
the wisdom of Jackie Chan we will do our
best what's up what's up with you
uh yeah I mean I was calling been a long
time listener
um yeah I have kind of a unique thing so
I had a great great job
um bought a couple cars in cash don't
have any debt other than the house since
jobs incomes going down a little bit
will go up significantly over time but
um yeah I just have been really
frustrated
by the amount of money that we've spent
on the two cars that they're in our
driveway I think just generally buy uh
the amount of money you're spending even
though we weren't going into debt we
were saving just so like we could have
done a lot better job with the income
that we've had the last several years
um so yeah they're sending some general
advice on uh the course specifically and
you know it's still like to bear on what
to do
um so on which is kind of in general how
many do you have
we've got two
um you only need one SUV for
uh no we we need to sell them
so selling them you're gonna have to go
buy two more cars then right
right
so here's another problem like I want to
know what's your gut reaction when I say
sell them
like is your thought uh I know I need to
sell I know I need to sell one for sure
right like we've got you know uh
probably eighty thousand dollars worth
of car and sitting in the driveway what
kind of car is this between the two
as two two cars between the two cars
what are the two cars
uh like a Volvo SUV
um and a uh an Audi that I made in the
purchase several months ago after a car
accident but I'm hoping to get rid of
the day so you they're worth 80 combined
yeah what's your household income this
year what do you think it's gonna be uh
yeah so it'll be we're dropping for
about 400 to 200.
well that's still a heck of an income
so parameter-wise ratio wise you're
still okay you got two paid for cars are
you just wanting to pay off the house
and you want to expedite this
you feel shame over this how did you
violate your own conscience here
yeah
um
what makes you think this was an unwise
purchase based on your income and where
you guys are at financially
um
I just like I look at it and just have
the sense that we could have could have
saved a lot more than than we did or
could be in a better position than we
are not that we're in a bad spot so
what's a better position in your mind
uh having a bigger bigger number in the
bank probably
um do you have a fully funded emergency
fund
yeah and you're investing 15 into
retirement
yeah and you feel like you're on track
how old are you guys
27. and how much do you have in
retirement
uh
I got 200 000. you're gonna have like
five or ten million dollars at
retirement
so when you're saying I could be doing
better where is that coming from
I don't know what how you define better
hey let me see if I can get it the other
day my six-year-old daughter was outside
and she was painting a picture
uh we I went to like Michael's and got a
bunch of these little miniature canvases
and she was painting and she was
listening to her music and being
demonstrative I don't know where she
gets that from but she was waving her
arms around and painting and my wife
said hey you're gonna knock over the cup
and she kept moving around and then she
knocked it over
fell down
and I watched her for a minute and she
just froze and sat there
and the water ended up moving all over
everything
and finally I said hey you've knocked
over the water
you can't put it back in the cup
you can choose to get up and go get some
towels so that it doesn't cause any more
problems
and then she got up and ran to go get
some time it was almost like I just got
like snapping your fingers to get
somebody out of there they got stuck
and you're wasting a lot of energy and
time and you're just wasting you're just
beating yourself up I don't and again I
don't know why
but the question is isn't we could have
we should have cool maybe you could have
but right now it's happened and the only
thing you can do is is sell the cars or
make peace with the cars in your
driveway as George said financially
you're fine if they're haunting you then
sell it man and then go about your day
but but sitting in we should have we
could have had you're just choosing to
poison today with decisions you made
yesterday you see what I'm saying
yeah yeah
and so I want to see like there's let me
say this this is not a situation that
you can think your way out of
you're just gonna have to go do
is that fair
Danny so will what's left on the
mortgage
uh
about 350 uh we've probably got 250 in
equity in it awesome so even making 200k
you said your income dropped how quickly
you think you'll pay off this mortgage
three years
yeah I mean I think we've had a longer
pull on the road I think it's just
trying to adjust stuff
fun to just change and do things faster
man I think we've gotten caught up in
just like Lifestyles number 27 and you
sound 60. you're doing so great
knock on any 27 year old's door and
they'll be like you may count you have
what you don't have any debt
there's people who are 45 still paying
off their student loans and here's what
we're calling we're going to call it
yours like I don't like this is what
Dave calls it but it applies here it's
your stupid tax congratulations
you made a ton of money at 24 25 26 way
to go you're changing you're changing
gears at 27 awesome you've learned hey
moving forward as we build up our
business back up and our income goes
from 200 back to 400 and then on to 800.
um we're gonna spend our money
differently we're just not Audi people
we're Toyota 400 people and I'm we're
great with that
um and we're going to pay our house you
see what I'm saying it's just about
saying yeah we recognized that was dumb
we're gonna do different next time
can you do that no it's super helpful
you can't yeah man nice I appreciate the
hell that's why we made the call uh so I
have to listen to this stuff the general
principles on YouTube for a long time
like probably at a kick in the butt I
can get it in person great you're a guy
who has very high standards for himself
I'm guessing
you are super driven to be doing what
you're doing making what you're making
at your age and I think it can be easy
for guys like you to beat themselves up
at every single Corner instead of just
being grateful and being free with the
contentment of man we are so blessed we
got a pile of money in the bank we don't
owe anyone anything we drive amazing
beautiful cars and remember that time we
need something stupid and we have done
some stupid things along the way and
we're just not gonna do them again hey
do me a favor will
stop talking so bad to Will
foreign
would you commit to that
yeah because you talk to will in a way
that if you heard somebody talking that
way to a waitress in a restaurant you'd
get up and knock their teeth out of
their head wouldn't you
uh some post to it yeah yeah you don't
suck you're not a loser you're not an
idiot you haven't bankrupt your family
you're not a terrible husband you're not
all these things that you say to
yourself on a regular basis I'm so
stupid it's so dumb I can't believe it
stop stop
stop
treat will with dignity and respect
because will deserves it Will's doing a
good job
cool
yeah I appreciate it thank you guys
thank you for calling brother appreciate
it
good stuff from will George I've been
down that rabbit hole man I make a
mistake do something dumb
and I just get paralyzed because I just
beat myself up man could have done
better John could have done better this
is classic John classic John way to go
deloney that's the one idiot yeah yeah
and it's on point you gotta make peace
of yourself and then go well if you look
in the rear view mirror long enough you
get a crick in your neck right so let's
look in the windshield it's a lot bigger
for a reason go your Future's bright
will we're proudy man way to go that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to Dr John deloney all
the folks in the booth and you America
until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]